è la troupe i ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono pari a oggi sono dati su ciò
ancora queste questa latenza con le mani
si vede proprio che ciò 24 anni siamo
grati fossero che ti dovevi racconto
della mia vita e oggi facciamo un
discorsino un po serio allora ragazzi
oggi vi racconto di vi racconto la
storia quindi farò soltanto una partita
perché una storia un po rock cannes
senso è una storia importante con un bel
significato che è successa pochissimo
tempo fa dovevo fare un evento no era un
evento nella mia città tra l'altro
torino era da un po che non facevo un
evento a torino era pieno pieno pieno
pieno di di gente eravate in un sacco di
persone quindi ragazzi vi ringrazio e
veramente magnifico che ad ogni evento
seat in così tanti da tutta italia
alcuni da tutto il mondo cioè l'ultima
volta che ho fatto un evento è stato
l'evento di just dance c'era una ragazza
da praga c'è da praga questa ragazza ha
preso l'aereo è venuta all'evento dove
c'ero io per incontrarli c'è stato
veramente splendido ok ora immaginate
questa cosa su larga scala cioè nel
senso quando è un evento ci sono tremila
persone ok tutte se tremila persone
magari un abitava la dieta quindi vabbè
ma molti di loro si sono fatte km molti
di voi che sta guardando questo video
saranno venuti ogni evento e magari se
vi siete fatti chilometri per venire da
me più volte
ragazzi io questa è una delle cose che
in assoluto ha prezzo di voi siete stati
veramente splendidi fino ad oggi e spero
di fare tanti altri eventi dove ci
divertiamo insieme insomma però la
storia che vi sto per raccontare molto
breve ma ci tenevo a raccontarla
nell'ultimo evento appunto c'erano
tantissimi di voi a un certo punto tra
l'altro tra parentesi a questo evento
qua c'era anche c'hanno anche i miei
genitori no perché era torino appunto
quindi sono venuti anche i genitori
visto che erano vicini
facciamo questo evento a rivoli pieno di
gente pieno pieno pieno pieno di gente
come tutti gli eventi facciamo le foto
insieme no e quindi iniziò a fare le
foto con tutti
purtroppo non riesco a stare tanto con
ogni singola persona ma sa che vi dico
basta basta webcam e basta va bene o
anche solo questo alimento che faccio
vorrei stare tantissimo che ogni singola
persona io riesco a scambiare quattro
chiacchiere come stai con temi seguita
però sono tante le persone quindi se non
riusciamo a fare in freccia poi alcuni
mano senza la foto quindi news
il vento ha continuato fino a che non
non è arrivato un ragazzo
ok questo ragazzo che era stato alto un
metro e novanta almeno dieci centimetri
più alto di me un colosso spesso anche
un bel ragazzo
a me piacciono le donne ma aveva una
faccia molto triste
io l'ho guardato e vi si avvicina a me e
io stavo per dirgli che è successo
perché comunque riguardava ma era un po
triste e aveva in mano a me sembra è
sembrato un panno all'inizio però in
realtà era una maglia da piccolissima
c'è una maglietta veramente piccola si
avvicina a me mi guarda e mi ha guardato
dritto negli occhi e lo hanno fatto in
tempo a dire niente lui mi fa ciao
lorenzo io oggi sono qua per dirti una
cosa ti devo dire una cosa molto
importante
io l'ho guardato gli ho detto di b lui
mi guarda e mi dice forse in assoluto la
cosa più importante barra toccante che
io mi sia mai sentito dire in tutta la
mia vita io sono qua perché
ho perso mio figlio all'età di sei anni
mi pare fossero sei anni non vorrei
sbagliare però mi pare di sì e l'ultimo
ricordo felice che io ho di lui
eravamo io e lui che che guardavamo un
tuo video insieme cioè lui mi ha detto
questa cosa io l'ho guardato e non
sapevo che il contratto era molto
giovane avrà avuto non dico la mia età
va 27 28 anni insomma ci secondo me i
trenta non arrivava quindi era
giovanissimo mi sono un po rispecchiato
in lui perché lui era veramente non dico
mio coetaneo però era un ragazzo come me
era un ragazzo come me
quindi lui mi ha detto questa cosa non
sapevo che cosa dirgli lui subito ha
fatto una cosa mi ha detto di oggi sono
qua perché voglio darti questo ricordo
di lui e mi ha dato la sua maglia che
indossava quel giorno quando guardava
panda quando hanno guardato il video con
me si sono sono stati felici insieme e
mi ha dato questa maglia piccolissima
che io qua perché ovviamente l'ho tenuta
questa qua e la maglia io all'inizio
quando è successa questa cosa l'ho
guardato io non ho saputo dirgli niente
l'ho abbracciato fortissimo lui aveva lì
mentre mi diceva queste cose aveva le
lacrime agli occhi non stava piangendo
ma aveva gli occhi lucidi simi io pure
quando mi ha detto quella roba io ho
iniziato a
stavo per piangere poi però il problema
era che eravamo davanti a tutti e quindi
era una cosa molto toccante non stavo
riuscendo a trattenermi allora in quel
momento è venuto mi è venuto proprio
spontaneo l'ho abbracciato fortissimo
non ci siamo detti niente ci siamo
abbracciati fortissimo per una decina di
secondi forse anche di più ed è stato
uno dei momenti più assurdi della mia
vita perché una cosa del genere se ci
pensate ragazzi è veramente non saprei
neanche come descriverla e poi dopo che
ci siamo abbracciati ragazzi lui è sceso
dal palco dicendomi di oggi sono qua non
solo con i miei occhi ma anche con
quelli di mio figlio
insomma della serie come se poi avessi
portato qui anche lui lui è sceso dal
palco
io l'ho guardato gli ho stretto ancora
una volta alla mano perché non riuscivo
a lasciarlo andare mi sono sentito parte
di questa cosa in prima persona
quindi io non riuscivo a staccare lo
sguardo da lui e per me l'evento in quel
momento era andato in standby mi sono
fatto forza poi ho continuato a fare
l'evento perché in quel momento io avrei
voluto sedermi davanti a lui e parlare
insomma di tante cose
eravamo in una condizione difficile
ho cercato di dedicare il tutto quello
che potevo per che comunque era una
situazione molto drammatica era una
situazione importante
sapevo che per me significava tanto e ho
cercato di dare tutto me stesso e lui è
sceso dal palco è andato a dire questa
cosa anche a mio papà no che era lì mio
papà
penso che lui abbia pià anzi sono sicuro
che mio papà abbia pianto e niente io a
me questa cosa ha toccato in primis
perché va bene nero il diretto
interessato ma per mio padre
e ancora vi toccate perché sa che cosa
significa perdere un figlio perché sa
che cosa significa avere un figlio e
quindi non osa neanche immaginare il
dolore che si possa provare nel perderlo
quindi anche mio padre se l'ha
abbracciato tutto insomma oggi comunque
questa era la storia di oggi sono qua
per dire che sono comunque orgoglioso di
aver incontrato un padre con la p
maiuscola
così giovane ma che sa essere un padre è
incredibile perché è venuto a fare una
cosa una cosa splendida perché c'era
anche tuo figlio con me quel giorno
c'era con noi anzi c'era anche lui e lo
sai mi rivolgo a te direttamente perché
so che comunque stai guardando questo
video
io alla maglietta ce l'ho qui non c'è la
terrò sempre perché comunque
un simbolo importante un qualcosa che mi
ricorda quanto sia bello il mio lavoro
che mi rende orgoglioso e mi fa fare
questo mi riporta a dare il mio meglio
ogni giorno e sono contento che il tuo
figlio vi siate divertiti ci sono tante
storie tristi nel mondo non credo
neanche di avere il carattere di poterle
reggere perché comunque io sono un po
non lo so io piango facilmente quando
guardo i film questo del genere quindi
mi trovi nella condizione difficile però
sono contento del fatto che ci siano
molti di voi che ogni giorno si
divertano guardando i miei video ecco
perché comunque da queste piccole cose
possono nascere di valori grandi oltre
che un lavoro secondo me stiamo facendo
comunque del bene a qualcuno che neanche
conoscevano e anche questo che mi rende
orgoglioso oltre che aver fatto del mio
hobby ciò che poi mi aiuta anche a
vivere però questa cosa che va
oltretutto va oltre lobby va oltre il
lavoro questo va oltre ogni cosa
però in questo video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi
io concludo qua lasciate un commento mi
piace nel senso magari raccontatevi un
po se ci sono delle situazioni che
conoscete che avete vissuto in prima
persona anche perché il bello di youtube
che si può anche parlare nei commenti
eccetera io cerco di leggerli il più
possibile gli mando un bacio iscrivetevi
al canale e noi come sempre ci vediamo
ad un prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]